Quindi ecco il tatuaggio di mio padre, quella sono io
che paro mi nonna e quello è Maurizio Costanzo
Ciao ragazzi bentornati ad una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della puntata
di oggi è "Tatuaggi Orribili"
Per un tema così importante ho pensato di invitare all'interno
degli studios de casa mia una persona che
potesse in un certo senso essere un esperto
se non altro non conosco personalmente dei
tatuatori e quindi ho pensato che forse la
persona migliore per, diciamo commentare ciò
che vedremo deve essere comunque un artista
Ora io ho la fortuna di conoscere un disegnatore
Marvel, tra i suoi ultimi progetti ci sono
Iron Man, i Guardiani della Galassia e un
sacco di altre cose fichissime che riesce
a creare con le sue mani. Ecco perché è
con immenso onore e anche un pizzico di spocchia ed
è un piacere, piacere di avere ospite, del
grande ospite, piacere di avere ospite, Valerio
Schiti. Ciao Vale - Piacere! - Che è un gran
piacere! - Un grandissimo piacere - Ho detto
tutto? - Hai detto tutto - Vabbè, ho detto
tanto. Partiamo... - Noi non siamo tatuati
tra l'altro - Tu non hai tatuaggi? - No zero
- Io zero - Infatti non abbiamo titolo - Non
serve essere uno stilista per dire che sei
vestito di me...Nemmeno serve essere uno
crea saponi per dire che puzzi. Allora io
ti voglio onesto - Sarò franco...che cos'è?
- Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, decisi di tatuarmi
la scritta Kaos sul braccio, il mio tatuatore
ed io non eravamo molto tra virgolette studiati in greco e
il risultato fu che mi scrisse Kaos in grego
con però l'alfa che era una a. Siamo stati
costretti ad aggiungerci una rondine
- Io avevo letto "50 ex"
- Decisi di farmi questo
benedetto tatuaggio sulle costole, quindi
già immaginavo dolore - Gli orsetti Haribo
- ...Decisi di farmi come si vede le ombre
come quel poco che si vede, le ombre di Peter
Pan, Wendy e dei fratellini di Wendy
- Questo vabbè, Wendi pure... un po' un fantasma tipo
- Diciamo che la classifica è primo Peter Pan come carineria
- Che però esatto, è riconoscibile - Il
fratellino credo che abbia... - La proboscide
- E un durello - Eh beh - "Pensieri felici,
pensieri felici". Wendy con la lordosi - Wendy fantasma
- E poi c'è Pingu - Na rana che
è? - Lei continua - L'ho avuto così fino
all'anno scorso, poi ho deciso di sistemarlo
- Però l'ha un po' risalvato vedi? I dettagli,
l'orsetto, l'ombrello. Wendy è un po' comunque
però... - Wendy è sempre un po' sfortunata
- Che è difficile però - Ha aggiunto i
dettagli, l'orsetto, l'ombrello e Wendy, che
prima non c'era Wendy - Il durello è andato
via - Si - ...E' diventato l'ombrello
- Volevo raccontarvi del mio incubo di tatuaggio,
fatto da un tatuatore che non ha negozio però
ha lavorato presso alcuni negozi e lui
adesso, non avendo soldi comunque per aprirne
uno suo, lavora a casa - Raccomandabile - ...E ha deciso di farmi il ritratto della mia gatta, Mafalda, però
sembra tutto tranne che un gatto. C'è gente
che mi sfotte che sembra una caffettiera...
- Sembra con il pollice opponibile - Con le
mani tipo. Poi ti guarda malissimo...Ti vuole
ammazzare - Questo è il mio tatuaggio, fatto
in un momento in cui la mia vita era un disastro
- E' una massa di letame - ...Dovrebbe essere
un tornado, però se lo vedi al contrario
sembra una cacca - Wow! - Cosa? - Wow! - Cosa?
- Wow! Tu devi ascoltare il messaggio e non
devi... - Alla cieca - Ciao Gu ciao ospite,
ti racconto di uno dei miei tanti tatuaggi
ovviamente il peggiore. Quando andai a Bologna
insieme ad una mia amica, ci siamo tatuate
insieme sul fianco la faccia di un porco - Perchè?
- Tutto questo è nato perché siamo un gruppo
di amiche chiamate "Porcone" - E certo! - ...Non
ti sto a spiegare il motivo, e ovviamente
era un porco orrendo. Ho coperto con un altro
tatuaggio. Non tatuatevi mai un porco
- Però devo dire una cosa - Dilla - Non me la sento
di parlare del motivo per cui si chiamano
le Porcone, cioè nel senso credo che sia
anche bello lasciarlo un pochino così sospeso
- All'immaginazione - Ma anche perché siamo
passati dalle Porcone a comunque dei bei fiori
Guarda che è fatto bene - Sisi. Eh rispetto
a quello di prima... - E' un Van Gogh
- Poi sembra che abbia tipo i baffetti
- E' vero - In realtà no - Denti da cinghiale - E poi sembra un po' tipo così che ti guarda
- Esatto tipo... tipo come se t'ha visto ma
non ti riconosce - E' vero - T'ho già visto a te
Come la moglie di Trump c'hai presente?
- Sisi - Ti guarda sempre un po' tipo che...
Tu per coprire... - Devi fare una cosa ancora
più grande e se ti fa schifo ancora più
grande, finché alla fine non copri... - Tutto
il tuo corpo e diventi Fedez tipo, che probabilmente
è partito... - Con essere uno delle Porcone,
con la sua amica, a me e a Federico
- Lui si è tatuato un orologio. Ohh e questo... - Ma
è un c**o? - Non lo so - Ciao Gu e ciao ospite
mi sono fatta questo tatuaggio super poetico
- Super poetico, mi ha tolto le parole - ...Sono due visi che si incontrano in uno solo
- Ahah - ...Ma assomiglia a un pene - Eh si
un po' - ...Soprattutto quando allungo il
braccio e fa molto ridere perché la gente
mi viene a chiedere se io realmente abbia
fatto un pene sul mio braccio - Ma vantatene! - Si...
Tu "Guarda sembrano due visi che si
incontrano nel mezzo della loro vita"
"E' un c***o" - Io non le direi niente ma non
c'ho il coraggio di andare in giro...
Ok, dove ce l'ha poi? - Ma scusami l'hai visto?
- Si l'ho intravisto, aimè l' ho intravisto
- Sembra fatto dentro le chiappe ma... - Non
lo volevamo dire...c'eravamo trattenuti...eccoci qua
Noooo - Eccoci qua...Abbiamo capito
tutto - Ciao Gu, spero che come ospite riprenderai
tuo fratello ti prego, fallo per la mia saluta
mentale e psicofisica. Allora da come puoi
vedere, spero tu capirai è un tatuaggio di Harry Potter che ci tenevo tantissimo a farlo. Dovrebbe essere
una cerva ma sembra più un lama che ha fatto
un frontale con un tir. Devo ricoprirlo ma
non saprei con che cosa - Ognuno c'ha il patronus...
- Che si merita...non è che uno può, viene
fuori da se - Ragazzi - Ma c'ha le gambe...Non
c'è una parte del corpo giusta - Questo pelo irto
- E comunque Always...non ce la faccio
più non lo posso vedè. Ma che c'ha alla faccia?
E' stupendo - Anni fa appena compiuti i diciotto
anni mi feci tatuare un cavallo, perché faccio
equitazione da parecchi anni - Non fate equitazione!
- ...E insomma stilizzato mi rilassavo con
il cavallo, lo feci vedere ad una amica che
mi disse "Perché ti sei tatuata una giraffa
sul fianco?". Questo era il mio tatuaggio,
inutile dire che dopo pochissimo tempo l'ho
fatto coprire con un cavallo ancora più grande
- Perché la criniera va lungo la gamba? - E'un cavallo villoso
Però abbiamo visto cose che voi umani...cioè questo
almeno si è storto... - No ma questo è ottimo,
cioè questo qui è veramente dalle sfide
quelle lì... - Sette più, non s'allargamo.
Vabbè sei - Sei meno - Sei meno - Cinque
- Cinque però recuperabile...
Ma perché?...E' un genio, io questo me lo tatuo io. Madonna mia!
- Eh si, è proprio lei - E' proprio
l'esclamazione che ti viene vedendolo
- Mi hanno invertito due lettere, al posto che essere
Strength è Strenght - Un'onomatopea - L'altro è Alive
oltre che essere in rilievo, tutte
le persone che conosco dicono che sembra scritto
Alice - Anche Calvé potrebbe essere...la
maionese. Non è un paese anglofono l'Italia
per cui sai...bene o male...va bene così. Vuoi
mette con la Porcona
Io rido prima, non vale
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, ciao fratello dalla fantastica
risata, ti voglio raccontare di quando decisi
di tatuarmi il muso stilizzato di un cavallo.
Dopodiché per fortuna un altro tatuatore
è riuscito a sistemarlo e a farlo sembrare
un cavallo - Più che altro è tipo tremolante
- No cioè... - La macchinetta era ferma,
era lui... - No la macchinetta era ferma e
lui muoveva lei - Esatto...siamo a rota de
cavalli...se c'è un cavallo, tatuaggio
Allora salgo in cattedra, da disegnatore posso dire, i
cavalli sono difficilissimi, perché hanno
tutta questa muscolatura a vista che devi
conoscere bene, cioè è una cosa complicatissima
il cavallo - Non puoi improvvisarti con un
cavallo? - No no, perché viene poi...I grandi
maestri sono quei disegnatori, sai quelli
di Tex, che fanno cavalli in continuazione, cioè
tipo Claudio Villa, no il cantante, il copertinista
di Tex - Però che p***e! - Però che palle!
- Via sfida cavalli (Enrico) - Nono io non
lo so fare il cavallo - Ah perché io invece
sono bravo? Non si può copiare - Nono non
possiamo cercare reference - Non possiamo
cercare cavalli. Però scusa non vale perché tu disegni
- E vabbè mo vediamo perché...
- Ma tu hai detto che ci stanno tutti questi muscoli a vista
- Esattamente - Io non ne ho fatto nemmeno uno. Ah gli manca
una gamba - ... -  Ma non vale...ma sembra Denver
- Il mio (Enrico)
- Vale che ha proprio barato
e ha fatto un drago - C'ha anche gli zoccoli
sotto se vuoi far vedere questo dettaglio
- Vai col mio - Che è un cavallo dai, ti
va riconosciuto - Ci ho provato eh
- Ah qui abbiamo la nostra tatuatrice - Lo sguardo
intenso - E poi ragazzi qui abbiamo una...
Mi da l'idea di un dinosauro del mesozoico. Ma
che cos'è Enrico? - Guarda come un cavallo (Valerio)
- E' vero ma è mostruoso. Siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video, io ringrazio
Valerio per aver preso parte a questa follia
- Non dormirò mai più - No e soprattutto
non ti avvicinerai mai più ad un negozio
di tatuaggi. Ricordatelo! - Andate da gente
fidata, controllate gli stencil - O non andate
proprio. Voglio sapere se conoscete qualcuno
che ha dei tatuaggi orribili, siccome purtroppo... - O qualcuno che li cancelli - O qualcuno che soprattutto
li cancelli o li copra, ma se ne avete qualcuno
in particolare fatemelo vedere taggandomi
su Instagram - Fatecelo vedere - Si anche
lui, taggateci su Instagram, fateceli vedere
Come sempre vi invito ad iscrivervi a questo
canale, ad attivare la campanellina delle
notifiche per non perdervi i prossimi video
che usciranno. Noi ci vediamo il prossimo
giovedì sempre alle 14 con un altro Vita
Buttata. Ciao - Ciao
- Questo è un deforme
- No quello è un gladiatore (Vega) - Che
sembra la montagna di Game of Thrones - Esatto
E' armato di una fava - ... - E' una tartaruga,
ecco cos'è! - La famosa testuggine